you talk about when you went to Tisch
for film and television
what was the curriculum regarding
writing at that time and if you were to
take it today and teach a class there
what would you add to it what would you
change keep the same well there wasn't a
ton of screenwriting when I was there my
favorite class was screenplay analysis
you know in the know shocker there the
first produced screenplay that I read
was in that class we read the Silence of
the Lambs which was a really great
script and it was interesting because
that script was exactly 120 pages and
they always say one page equals one
minute so it was exactly 120 minutes two
hours and that got me thinking hmm how
would this writer and know that he's
going to end exactly two hours in 120
pages in and that and then in the course
of the class we learned about structure
and how important structure was and that
it was structured exactly to end on page
120 you said there were too many classes
on writing there and of course the ones
that were I'm yeah you you you loved how
would you expand on it today knowing
today's you know landscape in terms of
these different sort of core formats
mm-hmm what would you add to the
curriculum let's say they invited you to
come back as a teacher professor well I
think I would definitely emphasize
television the long-form scripted
television writing form and I would
probably emphasize low-budget filmmaking
writing something that could be shot on
a low budget
now films are being shot on iPhones and
they're getting released in theaters and
they're getting nominated for awards and
winning awards so I would go in and tell
these kids they probably already know it
but you can shoot a movie on anything on
any topic on any type of equipment and
if it's good and it has a great story it
could have an afterlife but it still has
to have that great story so it doesn't
matter what technology you use I would
say learn about screenwriting and learn
about structure and focus on the writing
first and in terms of the actual
breakdown of writing a screenplay what
do you think you would focus on more in
terms of structure or dialogue or like
for students yeah if you were to be come
back as a professor and have say with
the curriculum I mean I would most
definitely focus on structure the most I
think just flowing short tight
storytelling you know there's nothing
better than a two page scene that really
advances the story and surprises us and
you know brings up a turn and direction
and shows us an element of the character
that we didn't see coming you know it's
all about surprise and subverting our
expectations that's why it's so
important not to have cliches because
the audience that the reader doesn't
want to know what's going to happen
because it's compelling if they're
surprised so I would probably emphasize
that structure and surprising
storytelling not cliche storytelling so
you went into the program thinking about
the industry and knowing there were
certain films that you wanted to write
in a similar genre and similar voice
when you came out of the program
what did the real world show you what
was an eye-opener what was maybe a
disappointment what was more of an
unplanned sort of joyous discovery about
the industry well it took me a while to
realize that working in the industry at
a day job you don't have to be creative
they don't want you to be creative
unless you're in a creative position so
I was so obsessed with with selling a
screenplay and directing my first film
when I was in my early 20s and I was
doing my first day jobs as you know
interns as a administrative assistant as
a reader and I was always looking for a
way to impress the boss so that they
would eventually bankroll my film or buy
my script and what I didn't realize was
it was all about just working hard put
your head down work harder than the next
guy
then if you work hard enough and they
believe in you because you've worked so
hard and shown that initiative and taken
any job out there no matter how you know
any task they give you no matter how bad
or ugly or gross or whatever take that
job do the best job you can at it do it
120 percent and that's what's gonna get
you hired that's what's gonna get you
the better position to move up the
ladder so when you say they don't
necessarily want people that are
creative that's interesting so even if
you're a fantastic writer it doesn't
necessarily mean you're gonna get a
certain job where writing skills aren't
maybe at the forefront of what you're
doing mm-hmm
yeah like if you're working in
development your job is to evaluate
material and develop material for your
employers company you know it's not to
write your own script it's to find
material and find material that's right
for your employer and then develop that
material so that it can be a greenlit
film so if you're a screenwriter working
in development let's say you're an
assistant to a creative director or
director of development at a studio they
don't want you to be writing your
screenplay you know two hours of the day
they want you to support them and
finding great material elsewhere do you
think internships are good for someone
coming out of film school yeah I
definitely think so it can be
challenging because how do you pay your
rent if you're working at a free
internship you know and that's one
that's one challenge that I had as well
I used to do temp work I used to do
administrative assistant temp work at
the time and try to do internships at
the same time which was challenging oh
but yeah definitely internships but the
main advice is just work hard work
harder than the next guy that sounds
like a lot how did you juggle that well
it was tough I would try to get temp
jobs I would tell my supervisor was that
the temp company that I wanted jobs that
were only like one two or three days and
then hopefully that would make me enough
money maybe four
couple weeks and then those two or three
days that I wasn't working that week I
would go into the internship at the film
company Oh interesting it was tough but
I figured it out somehow
you